[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman is my co-host today
here on the ramsay show ramsay
personality best-selling author and
author of the brand new book that
launches tomorrow from paycheck
to
purpose
the clear path to doing work you love
now ken if a book launches tomorrow
that means today
is the last day to get all the bargains
that's right and we've put out quite a
bargain i mean first of all 20 bucks
is your entry point for this at
ramseysolutions.com and then we're gonna
give you the ebook the audiobook read by
me plus over a hundred dollars in other
tools like our resume templates uh a
video course that teaches you how to get
hired how to beat the competition right
now dave we have the biggest demand in
employee talent we've ever seen and it
is competitive and so that's a course
that comes with that purchase all a part
of that 100 plus of free items so we are
certainly uh bribing but it's one of the
greatest bribes of all time 55 of
americans are looking for a new job
right now
and if you want to stand out in that sea
of talent
passion and experience
uh you have to be very very clear and
ken has the process to do that from
paycheck to purpose one of the things
some of you discovered during the uh
aforementioned pandemic
was that life's too short to spend your
life doing things you suck at or you
hate
and or both
and so people are leaving stuff where
they're not ain't good at it they're
leaving stuff where they hate their
toxic environment they're sick of it
they want to move on they want to do
something with meaning and from paycheck
to purpose helps you do that in the
title it tells you that so yeah that's
the whole process by the way we we're
giving you both we want you to have a
fatter paycheck and and experience more
purpose and yet dave in that ramsey it's
not either or it's not either it's both
and it's not like i have to live my
purpose but i'm gonna work at a
non-profit for ten percent of what i
could make somewhere else no that's just
we'll grab that's exactly right and this
idea that i can't make a really good
living doing something that i care
deeply about it's a process and we
unveil that path interesting dave in the
ramsey solutions work study the full
study will come out first of the year
that 55 of americans looking for a new
job right now that's one little piece of
data from this study another piece is
that 64 of those americans that are
actually 64 percent are saying i want to
move but i'm not sure where to move and
again this book provides the clarity
that key word there clear path is this
isn't just grab your machete and go
we're going to point you on the right
path and show you how to do it even if
by the way you're working through the
baby steps i think a lot of people
certainly in in the ramsey solutions
tribe go okay i definitely want to work
on purpose but i'm paying off debt well
there are multiple maybe
more money get a bigger shovel as a
result of this and get out of debt
faster so
20 for the book today's the last day
that you get 100 worth of bonus tools
like resume templates guides video
courses all kinds of goodies included in
the audiobook the e-book everything in
there it's it's a deal
today is the last day from paycheck to
purpose by ken coleman number one
best-selling author esmeralda is going
to start off this hour in fresno hi
esmerelda how are you
hi guys i'm ready to get to talk to both
of you
better than i deserve what's up
okay so i'm kind of like corruptional
nurse and um
i get paid pretty well for what i do
just because of the environment that i
work in
and my goal is to become a school nurse
which actually got the position and i
should start soon
but i'm definitely going to take a pay
cut just because of the change of
environment and this is something that
i've been wanting to do for a very long
time because i'm just stressed and
overwhelmed and
the environment is just not the best to
work at
but
my
question is whether this is a good move
right now financially just because i
will be taking a pay cut how big of a
pay cut
it's about
fifteen thousand dollars a year what do
you make now
i make a hundred okay and you're going
to cut to 85 and be a school nurse is
that what you said yes but then in about
two to three years i'll be back at 100.
okay well let's talk about what the next
two to three years looks like before
that so where does that put you are you
single income double income
um double income my husband makes about
120 so
that's why he's not worried and he's
like you need to go for this if this is
something that you really want to do
because we're we have about
40 000 in debt so he's willing to buckle
down and pay all that off that's awesome
well have a 200 000 income between the
two of you sure so this is not just more
me and being scared of like hey you know
i went to school and got my rn and i
wanted to make 100 and i think it's just
more me
taking like
the drawback of taking the pay cut yeah
can i suggest to you esmerelda it may
not be just you
part of this i wonder i wonder if you're
worried about what other people might
say or are already saying when you go
from rn and this you know that's
obviously a very prestigious role and
moving into school nurse i wonder how
much of that is coming from what you
think other people might think or say
i think i don't think it's i think it's
just me if i had a goal of making a
certain amount
and how i am and
with over time here that the potential
is limitless but also i'm concerned with
my mental health and
obviously a little bit of safety because
it's getting a little out of control in
here at times i would say well esmeralda
you just laid out multiple reasons you
answered your own question as to why
this is the right move all of those
negatives are absolutely confirmation
that you need to move but the biggest
confirmation is that you've longed for
this you said i've wanted to do this for
a long time your husband is on board
that's a fantastic position to be in
financially this is not going to be that
big of a hit you're still going to pay
off that debt
and you're going to be happy and you're
going to be fulfilled
and i understand where you're coming
from but you need to give yourself a
break because you have in fact achieved
that goal but what's great is you now
realize that that goal doesn't match up
with your heart and you got to follow
your heart here esmeralda step into this
this is a great move there's nothing
wrong with this move this is the right
move what's the uh what's the worst case
scenario you take the new job
and you get over there
and you hate it
and 20 seconds later you can be an rn
again in a hospital
oh no yeah i can so you're not this is
not a part this is not like uh you've
burned all the boats and you can't go
back home
you know
so you you can do whatever you want to
do go try it
and if it doesn't work go back to being
an rn
in a less toxic environment someplace
some other hospital some other situation
would be an rn at the school i know but
i'm saying go back into the medical
world rather than the school nurse world
and um if you don't like it if you like
it you know it it this is a no
lose scenario because you you can
in the world that you live in you can
get another job in 26 seconds if you
decide you don't want to be a school
nurse anymore after a year
so do it absolutely go
do it esmerelda yes that's exactly the
way this works guys so what ken does
every day on the ken coleman show if you
want to talk careers we'll do that you
wanna talk money we'll do that the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five or we'll talk about
your mama you're right in front of you
if you want me to whatever you wanna
talk about we're here it's that simple
the book is from paycheck to purpose the
clear path to doing work you love on the
streets tomorrow last day today of the
pre-sale at ramsey solutions.com with
all the goodies get it while the
gettin's good
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to the ramsay show common sense
for your dollars and cents
in a culture where common sense is so
rare that if you have it it's like
having a super power
ken coleman and i are here to help you
with your life your money your career
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five devin is
calling us from japan well there you go
hi devin
hi dave i'm looking for
short term housing for about two months
out of the year
when we come home
come back to the states in the summer
time my wife is a teacher
and in the fun and i'm a retired
military
so in the summers when we come home we
need a place to stay for about two
months
and we don't own property right now and
with the way the market is right now is
i don't see
when that could actually happen
but should we buy a house or is there a
good
way to find i didn't think so and i was
really warm to that i've tried airbnb
but um airbnb just seems really
overpriced to me
so i'm looking are there any other
alternatives to that
um there's some corporate housing stuff
out there in the hotel world
uh where somebody's coming to town to
work and they'll it's like a corporate
suite thing it's not necessarily the
best in the world but i would probably
prefer an airbnb or a vacation setting
of some kind um and it just depends you
know what i've done on uh not airbnb but
on vacation housing
is uh and i did it not long ago i
negotiated with the owner i said listen
i'm not going to be there for a week and
i'm not going to be there for a weekend
i'm going to be there for a month
now
you don't have to change anything out
you don't have the labor you don't have
the turnover you don't have somebody
tearing up your stuff
this was a luxury property i'm going to
be there a month i didn't stay the whole
month but sharon did so uh i had to come
back and work but anyway so we we rented
the thing
and it was in effect like an airbnb type
thing there's a luxury
uh uh vacation rental and uh i just
negotiated with a guy now i got to tell
you the first three people we went at
said no we went full price and i said
well you're not the one then
and uh because guess what there's three
more down the street and i'm going down
the street down the street down the
street until i find one
and i think that's what you're looking
for so you may have to get something
that's not your first choice
but um i think you shop around in that
world and you go at it with this is a
two-month deal it's not a weekend rental
and you should get a different reaction
if you put your shoes on the other feets
what i was doing i was saying i mean put
the put where are the other guys
moccasins if i had a vacation rental up
i would do a deal that way sure yeah
because i'm getting some i don't have to
screw with it right and somebody's not i
don't have the wear and tear of
three bachelorette parties versus a
stable family
you know coming in and out of there
which nothing will tear up a house like
a frat or a bachelorette party they'll
just tear up anything right so wild yeah
crazy
it just depends here on his situation
too where he's staying where they're
coming in do they have any community
where they come back to for a small
amount of time and putting the word out
too i wouldn't overlook the idea of like
putting the word out saying hey here's
our situation you know rates can be
really high on these vacation homes yeah
some local pastors if your mom and dad
are in a church in that market or your
brother's in a church in that market
tell them check with their pastor and
say hey my you know my brother you know
they he served
his wife's a teacher
and uh by the way thank you for your
service yes absolutely and uh that's the
best idea i got dude off top of my head
uh that and you can check some corporate
housing uh
those things are
typically not as
good a property as a good
vacation rental
a good one
rick is with us rick is in houston texas
hi rick welcome to the ramsey show
so i recently lost my job i was on a
step 3d so i had 10 000 in my savings
for my emergency fund and uh 17
in my separate savings i was saving up
for a house fund
if i need to start pulling from
my savings before i'm able to land
another job should i be pulling from the
house fund and leave the emergency fund
alone or should i be pulling from the
emergency fund itself
i don't think it matters because you
could rename either one of them at the
drop of a hat right
well i guess i didn't think of that yeah
yeah it's just twenty seven thousand
dollars we've got between us and
problems
and so um but i i probably
philosophically would start with the
house fund uh here's the thing though i
really don't want you to tap it at all
when did you lose your job
friday from what why
um there was a training incident
i was training a guy and
there was a undercharge in one of the
units and
you know they terminated both of us
okay
all right what kind of work are you
looking for
uh i'm a process operator in the
chemical field
okay
uh in your area of houston texas i'm
assuming you've done a cursory check
what kind of jobs are open is there a
lot out there or is it a little bit
tougher
yeah typically they do the most hiring
in the spring but there's a few here and
there that'll hire at this time of year
it's just uh
you know well and they probably are
short-handed right now right you
probably got some people that are that
normally would hire in the spring but
they've got some empty seats yeah
right what kind of money were you making
um i was at a
base salary at 95 000. yeah you know i'm
with dave on don't touch it at all and
i'll tell you why wall street journal
headline over the weekend uh
companies that said something to the
fact of no experience no education no
background check required that was the
headline and that's where companies are
right now and we're talking about big
time companies and so i just think that
the market is so hot in the interim
while you're applying and you're making
the connections and getting interviews
i mean dude you could be making
somewhere between 15 and 20 an hour uh
just to kind of keep things going i just
wouldn't touch that account i don't
think you need to i think you're gonna
start making some money by friday yeah
and uh while you look for this job and i
think you'll land a job in two weeks so
i don't think you're going to end up
touching it but you can make 15 20 an
hour doing almost anything right now
because there's such a hurt in the
market yeah uh and so and it may not be
what you want to do but rather mess up
your house fund is what i want to do sit
on my butt at home and mess up the house
fund no i'll go i'll go do something
else something unpleasant that i didn't
really sign up for
uh until this gets solved but i think
you're going to land something if you'll
uh get on this really really fast so ken
um
the first thing he should do in his job
hunt
is what first thing i want him to do is
look at what's open out there and then
he immediately goes okay who do i know
i'm looking at the connection
because he's got experience and skill
yeah okay and so he's immediately going
all right company xyz abc are both
hiring a position i'm ready to go who do
i know over there so i can fast track
and get above the applicant system and
what i mean by that is you know somebody
rick and they say all right yeah man
i'll put in a good word for you i work
in building b the guy who's hiring is
over in building a i'll walk your resume
over and put a handwritten note on it if
they're not in their office and go hey
i've known rick for 18 years that's the
play here and then
then you go through the applicant system
but you want to have a good impression
before you ever get into that and they
go okay we're going to fast track an
interview for rick that's what we're
trying to do first get your foot in the
door and you got to know somebody to get
in and get past the 30 000 resumes in a
stack
and
the book he's referring to the concept
he's referring to is the proximity
principle it was the number one
bestseller rick i'm going to send you
that and i'm also going to give away my
very first copy that i gave away
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love so i'm gonna send
you both of ken's books the new one will
be a bestseller as well
um and then i want you to also i'm gonna
send those to you kelly's gonna pick up
and give you the stuff uh but go to his
website and download all of his free
downloads on resumes on letter writing
on the things you do to get your foot in
the door do not just go
apply for 8 000 positions at monster.com
and be surprised nobody called you back
that's a that's a fool's errand right
now
and let me tell you why that advice that
i gave is also so vital in this
situation it doesn't sound like there's
an ethical issue here but the fact of
the matter is rick was terminated uh and
yet we still have a super hot market and
people are okay with that if you own it
don't try to do a politician spin on
this stuff if it comes up own it uh own
it with confidence
humility i learned from this is a good
thing i totally get it don't throw the
old company under the bus here's how i
can help you win i'm ready to go don't
ever try to just kind of cover that
stuff up but when i asked him he gave
the perfect answer he gave a great
emotion it was not throwing the other
company on the bus he was not a victim
that's very clear very concise and
that's the exact answer he ought to give
up front in any initial interview so
that no one
catches later and goes well why don't
you tell us about this now tell them
right up front bust it bust that down
and move on move on move on move on this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
so
the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage kyle and brenda are with
us hey guys how are you good how are you
welcome where do you guys live delano
minnesota just outside of minneapolis
wow and all the way to nashville to do a
debt free scream how much have you paid
off
572 000. wow 383 dollars and 41 cents
wow how long did that take seven years
in two months all right and your range
of income during that seven years two
months yeah i was about 110 to 200 and
currently we're at about 140. okay cool
what do y'all do for a living uh
brenda's a stay-at-home mom and i am a
reporting analyst for a large health
insurance company cool
well i'm guessing by the length of time
and the huge amount of money you paid
off your house
and we also own a third of a lake home
too so one and a third houses i guess
technically all right all debt free 100
death don't know a soul in the freaking
world nope nope way to go guys look at
these weird people
uh these are weird people right here man
you guys are amazing congratulations
what a seven year journey that's
absolutely cool all right tell us the
story how did you get on our stuff for
seven years
yeah when our second child was we knew
they were on the way we put in our
spreadsheet that was less than accurate
and optimistic at best and the number
was actually negative so we knew that we
had to do something we didn't have
enough money to pay for daycare for our
second child and so we naturally i think
we went on facebook and then
when the tea where one of the students
ready the teacher will appear and
someone posted something about it
bought the total money makeover and i
persuaded brenda to
uh join in the joining the fun so a lot
of persuading
i'm glad he did okay so he reads this
book and says uh uh we can't pay for
daycare which you already knew yeah but
this is uh what we're going to do is
live on beans and rice rice and beans
live like no one else so later we can
live and give like no one else and you
said i don't think so yeah well i it
took a lot of convincing to you know the
slow steps of you want me to cut up my
credit card you want me to do what what
if something happens being a mom having
all those insecurities and then we just
went for it and we went crazy and
everybody calls us crazy you are crazy
you're wonderfully weird
i love it wonderfully weird so what did
he do that finally convinced you brenda
what did you do i don't i don't know it
was i think just staring down the the
just staring down that we had no other
choice i don't know what else to do so i
got to try this crazy right
right and he's my partner and i trust
him and so we just went for it okay and
then the more it worked the more you
thought this is smart right right we got
after it pretty quick i mean and
i was able to
quit my job and take care of our kids
before our third was born
we bought a brand new vehicle with cash
and it did all that before we even
started to attack attack the house in
the morning so how fast did you get out
of the non-mortgage debt it was a little
over two years like exactly what your
numbers were are normal
yeah and two years to do that seven
years pay off the house yeah and the car
she's talking about was a sweet minivan
so she might have left that part out
a sweet minivan let's just go ahead and
call it what it is sweet
so brenda you said something a minute
ago and i think this is this is really
good i'd love for for for moms and wives
to hear what you say about this when he
first approached you about this you were
like wait a second i got to cut up the
credit cards what if something happens
implying that you saw those credit cards
as a safety net and i understand that
and yet here you are now so what would
you say
uh which is a natural kind of that
mother you know like hey you i got to
take care i'm a mama bear
on the other side of this what would you
say to somebody who's listening and
watching right now they feel the same
way about this journey what i gotta
cut up their credit cards that's our
safety net what's the answer to that now
go get the scissors
i don't know it just is it's just you
um but can you have a safety net without
credit cards is michael oh absolutely
yes i've never even thought about
getting a credit card you absolutely can
so how did you approach that emotionally
as you started to walk through that
because you cut them up and then how did
you address that safety issue that
emotional need yeah that's a good
question i just trusted the process and
knew that it was there for me and it was
there to catch me as long as i put my
trust in there yeah that's good just for
a while because here you are seven years
later with a paid for house what's this
house worth
it's probably 250 yeah something like
that we got we got real crazy we
actually downsized our house yeah in
order to be debt-free sooner you
introduced us to the minimalist then we
gave away all our stuff and then we
realized we don't really need the big
house that we're in before and
opportunity came in that we were able to
get my
grandma's house and we downsized
everybody thought we were nuts and
two years later no here we are yeah a
lot of people thought you were nuts but
uh you're not you're you're on your way
to being baby steps millionaires in no
time i think so well done guys actually
we already are yeah you already are yeah
all right so how much in the 401k
uh it's probably like six it's like 600
and then the house and cabins 400
something so it's
plus our minivan is probably still worth
10. that's sweet minivan put them over
the top
there's your breakthrough that's your
wealth building break for it through the
sweet minivan way to go guys oh thanks i
love it well you did everything in order
you did it right you submitted to the
process and guess what the process
worked yep so you're not only debt free
house and everything baby step seven but
your baby steps millionaires as well
way to go i'm so proud of y'all what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
what we were saying about the budget and
how that's cliche so we we were going to
pull up the minimalist card and just say
like just keep an open mind and try to
listen to what other people are doing
and just keep learning and
it once you get going it just snowballs
and it's just rapid pace and
next thing you know you look back and
seven years later and you're done yeah
what about you brenda what do you tell
people the key is
um
the key is
definitely the budget but two i think
like the deprogramming of what the world
has told us that we need to have be
and how all of a sudden you look back
you're like wait i don't need all this
stuff i don't need this house i don't
need these things i just
need my life
i love it wow hey we got to send this to
joshua yeah
they will love this joshua and ryan they
will love this yeah that's really great
we had dinner with them last time they
were here up at my house and hung out we
had some great conversations until deep
in the morning they're they're
incredible guys so well done you guys
i'm so proud of you very very very cool
and you brought the kiddos with you to
celebrate
what are their names and ages drew is
nine will is
gonna be seven and reid turned five on
sunday all right very cool and if
they've been uh they've been plugged
into what you're doing oh yeah they know
that their lives are changed they do
there's no payments in your world
none ever again
i love it way to go you guys very very
very cool well we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you because that's
definitely the next chapter in your
story as you continue this baby steps
millionaire journey and i'll give you an
extra copy of total money makeover to
give away maybe you can start somebody
off like you guys started off on that
same book that sounds good and that's
how you got here well done you guys very
proud of you whoo i love it
man this is these people are weird
they're awesome they're awesome all
right kyle and brenda drew will and reed
from the minneapolis area
572 000 paid off in seven years making
110 to 200
house and everything
baby steps millionaires count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
[Applause]
yeah
man oh man oh man
can when you have a clear path and the
stuff she said we we i love the phrase
uh submit to the process
she said she said uh uh
deprogram program from the culture big
word because the culture's idiots that's
right in almost everything that's right
almost any area of life this culture has
lost its mind
so deprogrammed from that doing your own
thought your own independent critical
thinking uh my my good friend one of my
best friends is a pastor who says don't
let the world teach you theology
talk about deprogramming right and so
you know where are you getting your
truth from where are you what are you
dialing in on are you believing all
these broke people are they giving you
advice about money because they talked
about how many times somebody thought
they were crazy but look at crazy look
at crazy now baby crazy rich
love it
this is so fun
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm dave ramsey welcome to the ramsey
show ken coleman number one best-selling
author is my co-host his brand new book
comes out tomorrow
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love the baby steps
are a clear path to becoming a baby
steps millionaire
paycheck to purpose outlines the clear
path to doing work you love exactly step
by step by step what you need
to do
if you want the goodies all the pre-sale
items that go with it order it today and
you get an extra hundred dollars worth
of stuff that you won't get tomorrow all
for the same twenty dollars not a bad
deal our question today comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color they
will remake your blinds for free you get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more use the promo code ramsey
to get the best deal today's question
comes from john in indianapolis i have a
high stress job that pays 230 000 a year
in addition to dealing with aging
parents teenagers in the pandemic the
job is wearing me out and it's having a
negative impact on my life i've been
offered a new job where i'd take a 30 to
40 thousand dollar a year pay cut with
the same company but the work is
invigorating and entrepreneurial i'm
having trouble justifying this pay
decrease although i feel i'm going to be
happier our only debt is our mortgage
college is funded my wife earns a great
salary and we have a healthy savings
account so why am i struggling with this
decision i don't want to be one of those
unhappy people saddle with a job they
don't like yet they stay for the money
well
john then don't be one of those people
you don't want to be one of those people
so uh my mentor this guy to the left of
me
he's got a great little tactic when he
gives a speech and he's talking about
money changing you go
just aside just a little quick clap and
i think john you don't want to be one of
those unhappy people that stay just for
the money let me help you a little bit
you don't need the money a 30 to 40 000
pay cut right now
uh for you is going to take you just
below
200 000 a year and your wife makes a
great salary we don't even know that
number so you guys may be in that 300
000 range you're above 250
this work is clearly having a tremendous
impact on you all of the signs are there
you need to give yourself permission
to do the right thing and this is the
right thing i will also tell you that
this new job
being invigorating and entrepreneurial
tells me two things that there's
probably a path
back up to the money you're making now
if not going beyond that i don't have uh
that information in front of me but this
is the right move you don't need to feel
bad about it you're not doing the wrong
thing you know dave it reminds me you
know we heard our last the debt free
screamer talk about deprogramming
and this is an issue here where we are
so
programmed in our world to put
significance
and success completely in the financial
bucket and yet that's just simply not
the case and it makes people like john
feel like if i take a strategic cut
that i can absolutely absorb that
somehow i'm doing the wrong thing or
it's a dumb thing or a not smart thing
and i think that's real but in this case
john this is the right move all the way
around
i don't think it's dumb and i agree with
ken i would take it
however i think you need to keep in mind
that the aging parents and the teenagers
are still going to be there
so where's your stress really coming
from
what's really going on
i mean if you've got some family stuff
that's out of balance and you need to
set some boundaries have you got some
tough decisions you've been unwilling to
make
with either one of those other two
subjects
that are putting that are the real cause
of the stress make real sure you're
treating the right problem
not the symptom
and uh the second thing is this again
i'll agree with ken take the job john
however i do not agree
with the supposition that the only way
you find happiness is to move down an
income
that you can't find something that's
invigorating what was the phrase he used
an entrepreneurial that pays 300 000 a
year
why is it we always think to be happy we
have to make less money what is this
stupid thing that's floating around in
this culture that says that
by the way if you do something you love
you're better at it and you should make
more money
ultimately yeah i mean but this idea
that you have to have poverty associated
with happiness or less money associated
with happiness is absurd so i would
choose a third option as a consideration
and that is where can i find something
invigorating entrepreneurial that pays
300.
oh
why is it we have to go down all the
time i don't understand this so anyway
it's okay if you do and i'm going with
ken's recommendation but i'm going to
challenge you on those two points make
sure you got the parents and the
teenager thing working because dude
that's still going to be there yep and
you got to be careful what you think the
stress is so you know the first time
that happened to me is when i filed
bankruptcy
the bankruptcy attorney
um
didn't do a lot of things right but he
said one really wise thing
he said uh because you're you're under
this tremendous weight
of debt which feels like he feels right
you got this overwhelming anxiety over
the top of you and where you're like
something's standing on your chest i
can't breathe and then the day you file
bankruptcy that that's just poof you
know most of it anyway is gone right
and you got some more stress points but
by and large i've been fighting it for
two and a half years i was ready to sit
down the rock baby okay but that guy
looks at me and he goes you know what
filing bankruptcy does not create an
income
yeah mic drop yeah that's right it's
really good you know it's like you know
you're not going to prosper
because you filed bankruptcy you've
still got to go out there to kill it and
drag it home whatever it is you still
got to find a way to eat
and of course i responded i got this
figured out but but i mean it's still i
can remember that 30 years ago i
remember that conversation right now
and so that's what i always think you
know be careful what you wish for
because it might may not be touching
what you're talking about you're still
the common denominator you're still
going to be in the next marriage you're
still going to be in the next job your
parents and your teens are still going
to be there after you make this move
you're the common denominator follows
you everywhere i'm glad you brought that
up because
he could take this move and it could be
on paper all the things that he says it
is
but if the personal life is burning
the job doesn't solve that right it will
help right in some ways you've got some
purpose as you move into the office but
if it's 70 job stress and 30 family
it'll help it'll help if it's the other
way around it's not going to make a
difference you're just going to make
less money
exactly right and i think that was a
really great call out here and i would
also agree with you in this situation if
that's the only thing that you've got
but it's rarely the only thing and this
is situation well i've got an
opportunity here
and it's going to be better in all these
ways and it's less money and i think
you're right you got to consider the
whole field the whole universe of jobs
samantha's in charlotte north carolina
hi samantha welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi ken it's an honor to speak
with you both
you too how can we help um
well my husband and i have well we're on
baby step seven we have five different
retirement accounts between us both i'm
wanting to open a sep ira uh with our
business to reduce our taxable income
but my question is is there a maximum
number of retirement accounts a couple
can have without being penalized somehow
no
there's not a maximum you can do you can
do whatever you need to do
if you have too much money sitting in an
old 401k or old ira it could affect your
roth contributions but that's all
um and so but those are old but in terms
of can you do it you can do a sep ira
you could do a sep roth ira instead
you can do a roth ira at the same time
and your husband can do his 401k over at
work now the sep is
any employees have been with you more
than three of the last five years
are also going to get the same
percentage of their income that you put
in the percentage of your income into it
so do you have employees been with you a
while
we do not okay so you can put in up to
about 13.6 is what the calculation is
going to end up being 13.6 of your uh
profit on that business your taxable
income on that business can go into that
sep and you can make it a a roth sep is
what i would do and get with one of our
smart vester pros at ramsey
solutions.com
and get signed up for that
and uh um you know they can help you
walk through the process but you know
there's a lot of different kinds of
accounts you can have 401ks you could
have uh you could have a 401k at your
work he could have a 403 b at his work
um you could have seps you can have uh
ir individual iras at the same time uh
as you've got all these others that
there's you know there's a couple of
them there's one or two of them that
overlap now now and each of them have an
in each of them have a contribution
limit that you can do
but uh but the number of accounts no
by and large there's very little if any
limitation on that so good question ken
coleman ramsey personality my co-host
today here on the air this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for jumping in the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
today is the last day to order his new
book from paycheck to purpose the clear
path to doing work you love for twenty
dollars and get a hundred dollars worth
of pre-sale items thrown in
all kinds of goodies there you can get
the video course guides templates resume
templates you can get the audio book and
the e-book all included the pre-order
ends tonight because the book goes on
sale in bookstores and around america
all day starting tomorrow and all of you
that have pre-ordered the book they will
all ship uh this week to you so you're
going to be getting them as soon as
possible uh we've been able to uh work
through the uh
uh pandemic paper shortage and got the
book got the books out no question got
them out into uh into target and into
barnes and noble
and into that fine french store and um
uh all those places right and all the
places great books are sold and uh of
course amazon has them and of course
ramsey solutions has them if you want to
do the pre-order and get all the deal go
to ramseysolutions.com
today today's your last day gary's with
us gary is in kansas city hi gary how
are you
hi dave team ramsey uh
honor to speak with you you too
i wanted to uh just go over
what's in my life in my brother's lives
a little bit of a complex uh
question question we need answered
regarding uh
my mom who died a couple of months ago
and uh some of the far out from that
oh thanks what happened what did she
pass away from um
i think officially it was covet however
there was more to it she was she had a
lot on her mind she was dealing with my
dad who had dementia
she was uh
lived a life of service and entertaining
for us and just provided her life that
she was very joyful person and a lot of
friends a lot of uh
a lot of great relationships she
established and we uh
we were just blessed for a couple of
show weeks ago you mentioned uh what we
inherit from our parents you know a big
cash nest egg and all maybe that's not
so good but instead is better a
a work ethic and i think we got that
from my parents god god bless them you
know
anyway we miss him please her fiercely
and uh
so
it's it's part of it's
so that's joy but there's a sad part
that we're trying to work through
she was scammed the last two years of
her life pretty pretty and she bought
into bought into it pretty
pretty deeply um and we were sort of
tracking it but not real uh
not as close as we should have this as
i'm remote from her i have
some some mega million scam or something
uh
got it got into her head and uh
she was very uh concerned about you know
providing some kind of uh inheritance
for her for us
is your dad still is your dad's still
alive
he is and and yes he he's with us and
my middle brother is really stepped up
and he's he's doing dad basically taking
the place of what my mom was doing so
did she lose all of their assets
in a word yes okay she has sold a house
about a year and a half ago all the
proceeds spent and
there's nothing left but debt
the debt is the debt is not that so the
debt is like kind of small but it's so
where we're going with this question is
the ethics of it so
she had in this scam the the scammers
had convinced her to buy three iphone
12s
and and and they would reimburse her in
all this and it was somehow how she was
going to pay the taxes as well that's
where a lot of the money apparently went
then he had a she uh so she bought these
three iphone twelve they're a thousand
bucks a piece and uh
a big cell company or a big
um
one of the big ones um
now has this bill out she wasn't getting
the
installments of
funding that were said to be coming from
the scammers of course so at the point
where she was seeing she bought these
phones and then of course shipped them
off
all at her expense
with the cell phone
provider companies whatever
they uh
they they got free two free phones she
kept one of them and now she wasn't
gonna pay the
financing find it you know your finances
these things and then she was i guess
kind of so she didn't pay the three
thousand dollars off we still have this
three thousand dollar bill
and
there's nothing to be redeemed as far as
her credit because her credit shot she
had a great credit she did great things
with her money for her life when you
pass away gary
what you own
stands good for what you owe
and so she has a 3 000 debt
does she own
your dad and her own
anything
he's got
a car
um
there's there's little penny any stuff
that is around a car
the uh i mean there was some
some little some hard assets that were
were uh able to uh
liquidate an event that wasn't even to
be done but we weren't really uh
uh
they come after her estate that i guess
that's all they can do they can come
after her estate and if you guys sold an
antique dresser for ten thousand dollars
and kept that money instead of paying
this bill
then they would have recourse against
you guys
okay so yeah
she uh saddled us with this it sounds
like yeah what you own
stands good for what you owe
when you pass away but your kids do not
inherit debt but your kids will not get
an inheritance until the debt is paid
out of
the things that they owned your mom and
dad owned
where is your dad living
he's in a a memory care facility
[Music]
so he's got a checking account with
three thousand dollars in it
yes there's that yeah we've got a little
bit of
uh my brothers and i are all if this is
the only debt that there is
you're gonna have to pay that debt in
order to clear the rest of the assets
even though they're penny annie
it's not ethics it's the law
yeah okay
and they that you know they're probably
for three thousand dollars not gonna
chase you guys down and you know put you
in a headlock and and you know try to
get the three 3000 bucks out of you if
it's a practical matter but that's
technically the way this works and so
morally the way this works
understood
yeah you're gonna you're gonna have the
unhappy experience of completing the
scam
right goodness um
okay and how prevalent is this is this a
very proud i need to
do i need to get as i retire from my
military should i go into
detective work in cyber and in regards
to trying to protect elders from their
yeah
the only problem is the people that will
be paying you are broke because they've
been scammed
uh but yeah it's pretty prevalent that's
a pretty standard the iphone scam you
know that whole thing that's fairly
normal we hear it sadly more often than
we should
and um
yeah it's
it's it's pretty prevalent but i don't
know whether you can make an income
doing it or not that's a whole nother
discussion
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personalities my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five
so if you suspect
that a loved one is being scammed
suggested steps
i think you have to have a sit down with
them and say hey i think something's
fishy here can we dig into this and try
not to put them on the defensive but ask
some questions dig in uh do a little bit
of uh your own version of a private
investigator and uh dive into it and
then show them hey this doesn't seem to
make a lot of sense and many times they
just need somebody else to kind of look
at it and go hey this doesn't seem right
and i think that's the first thing i do
and if it's not right i'd say hey this
is a bad idea we're going to get you out
of this let me help you know because i
think there's a certain amount of
embarrassment there oh always think
about that you know so go in i go in a
little easy i'm trying to put myself in
the shoes of talking to my father you
know if he were to have that situation
and i'm going to have to come in there
and not embarrass him not make him feel
like he was totally duped make the bad
guy the bad guy not them the bad guy
that would be my approach that's exactly
right that's exactly how you do it and
it's really not hard to research these
scams that's correct well a simple
google search will pop up in front of
you and uh you know
mega millions scam spanish letter scam
nigerian letter scam there's several
versions out there
and uh um
the people get sucked into all kinds of
different things and just if you just if
you have enough information you know
where there's cell phone and mega
millions both mentioned all you do is
type that in boom it'll pop up show you
exactly what they're doing how they're
working it yeah what's going on and then
you just can send that link and go
listen this is what's happening to you
yeah yeah let's get you out of there and
so um you know you didn't do anything
wrong no uh you were just trying to
leave an inheritance what a horrible
motivation
but uh the number of times i've seen
people
in the name of leaving an inheritance to
their children
get into stuff they should not get into
is over 30 years of doing this it's all
the time oh i'm sure bad financial
products scam real straight up scams
like that lady got scammed um but all in
the name of i want to leave the kids
something which is a misguided thing to
start with the most important thing you
can leave them is to not do that kind of
stuff well you know i just i've learned
this you know if it's too good to be
true it's almost always
yeah
if it smells fishy there's fish involved
i mean come on
you know if you think if you i got a bad
feeling you know why you got this this
just felt weird you know why it felt
weird because it was weird oh yeah
that's why i felt weird yeah and trust
yourself you know yeah i'm glad you said
that so you know i'm a big nerd and i
read a lot i was reading a book i'm
reading a book right now by a physicist
and you know you talk about you it's
legendary you talk about sharon dave's
wife sharon she's she's got incredible
great great great common sense you
always talk about that feeling you say
it the way that i can't say it but you
can say it
there it is
and but you know there's actually the
physicists have done research on this
real quick they had they put heart
monitors on world-class grand master
chess players
to find out if that gut feeling is that
a gut feeling or is it actually tied to
the same mechanism that we kind of say
well i logically thought through this
decision long story short this grand
master chess player's heart rate spiked
every time in the match before they made
an incorrect move and the the so the the
conclusion was that gut feeling
that's actually your brain sending a
physical response to your body and your
heart is warning you
don't do it don't do it and so i just
wanted to point out that when you have a
bad feeling
don't put that off as a gut thing as
some mysterious thing that's your brain
and your body combining to go stop
yeah
but i had a weird feeling about him
you know that's because he's weird right
you know
that's just you know that's the thing
it's just trust yourself yeah and um you
know because you know that about 20
times while that lady was sending off
that money of those cell phones and
selling her house to do this that she
had those things you know she had an
inkling
that this was wrong and so the way you
can step in is to tap into that and say
you got to trust yourself
because yourself is telling yourself
this is not this bad deal this is a bad
thing trust yourself and i used to say
trust your gut instinct and my friend
who's a pastor said that's not your gut
that's the holy spirit don't call the
holy spirit your gut
trust god's spirit that's in you which
will speak to you and say don't do it
yeah yeah that's it
yeah and your body is sounding more like
a demon than it did it kind of did but
hey that's kind of what we have to get
rid of sometimes right
alex is with us in minneapolis hi alex
how are you
hi i'm doing good how are you today
better than i deserve how can we help
hey so my husband and i are both about
30 respectively we make about 200k
together
uh we have a little baby just one kid we
have no debt
we are investing in full we tithe in
full
etc um we also have our six month
emergency fund saved up and we have a
little bit of extra money look
i'm saved we've got about 40 grand on
top of our six month emergency fund that
we're not really sure what to do with
um
we were thinking about putting it into
our house to pay against the principal
yeah the only time to be in the house
for another three years or so it doesn't
matter
pay it off anyway
pay it off anyway as fast as you can
okay we can do that yeah you should be
putting no more than you should be
putting no more than 15 of your income
currently
into retirement
and you should be saving for your kids
college and every dollar that you have
beyond that after having a reasonable
life because you're at a good stage of
this goes towards the house that's what
we call baby steps four five and six
now when the house is paid off then i
would go back and i would max out
retirement but until then i want this
house paid off because we've discovered
in our study of millionaires the largest
study of millionaires ever done in north
america that the typical millionaire the
first million to two million dollars
worth of net worth that they gain is
from a paid for house and a funded
retirement
okay not one or the other it's both
that makes sense we thought that wasn't
the answer we're just nervous about it
it's okay it's okay here's the thing
you're not gonna lose the money by
paying the house mortgage down because
if you do sell the house within three
years which you're anticipating they're
gonna write you a check at closing all
that money comes back out
yes so do you i mean it sounds like you
recommend that over we're planning to
move and we know where we want to go
next by buying a piece of property so
you recommend
paying the house instead of putting
money on the property right away yep
yeah
okay
because the two things i run into are
not a paid four third piece of property
in the millionaire study i run into paid
for houses
and fully funded retirement plans that's
what we run into all the time that's
where the data leads me and so i think
i'm going that direction every time
there
every time so good question dave what's
the emotion there because she's they're
they're amazing what an unbelievable
job so they're such a good job yes
what's the emotion there where's that
come from on that what's behind that
this is a person who's very smart with
their money should i put that 40 000
into the house when i'm moving in three
years what what's what's causing that to
think oh we don't know if that's smart
is what she feels it feels like it's
trapped
it's like the money's trapped okay can't
do anything with it it's in now in the
house okay and that is that makes sense
by the way that's also a good thing
right because you don't accidentally buy
a bass boat with it you know um
oops
there's that boat in the driveway it is
true yeah and so when you trap it in
there but it does feel like oh i can't
get it back out i can't get to it that's
good um and that's why you know someone
who's that smart i still remind them
even though i know they know this that
they're gonna get their money back out
of the house when they sell it
because you need to emotionally feel
that oh it's not really gone i'm just
storing it there
that's good storing it as opposed to
being stuck it's not stuck it's stored
yeah and it's it's it's got a lock on it
that's key on it but it's stored
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five today is the
last day to order ken's brand new book
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love
and you can order it today and get for
twenty dollars and get a hundred dollars
worth of extras including resume
templates video courses guides
resume guides and the audio and the
ebook all included if you order today if
you order tomorrow for 20 you will get
the book
today you got all the other stuff yeah
move on it tomorrow's launch day so get
on it while you can ride at
ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today on the debt-free stage in
the lobby of ramsey solutions tyler and
melissa are with us hey guys how are you
doing good hey dave welcome where do you
guys live
so we live in a small town called
trenton it's near cincinnati ohio it's
about 12 000 people in it okay cool well
welcome to nashville good to have you
and all the way here to do a debt-free
scream how much did you pay off so we
paid off 49
992 dollars love it how long did that
take it took two and a half years okay
and your range of income during that
time about 60 to 70 000 although at one
point it was about 40 when i had a back
injury and was out of work
what do y'all do for a living so i'm a
sewer pipe inspector
at a company called televac
environmental
and i'm a wedding photographer and a
stay-at-home mom oh fun good for you
guys so what kind of debt was this fifty
thousand dollars
mainly my stolen my student loans and
then car
um
medical bills credit card debt just the
whole nine yards pretty much so how long
y'all been married a little over four
years okay
so two and a half years ago something
happened and you start this ramsey
journey stuff what'd you do what
happened so what happened was our church
the little church in hamilton ohio they
ended up hosting a financial peace
university class
and that changed it all so i i just want
to give praise to the the people the
leaders for that mike and liz knutson
like
really changed their lives wow
very cool so you you go in there and
they're they're announcing it on sunday
morning that there's going to be a class
and you decide to take it yes yep we
knew there was we knew the way we were
handling our money
wasn't the greatest and we just knew it
could benefit our family and we had a
lot of weight from like medical bills
when we our daughter was born just a
little bit before that so
kind of that pressure i kind of like
pushed us into it yeah okay cool yeah
there's something about having that
first kid and then there's some bills
laying around you're like i gotta get
this mess clean now yes yeah kind of a
wake-up call huh mm-hmm yeah way to go
proud of you guys great job
very very cool okay so what did you do
to get out of debt tell people what the
key to getting out of debt is
so there i mean there's a lot of keys
for us
a couple of them was like vision you
know we had to have a road map kind of
figure out where no what's coming in
what's going on
communal care right we had support from
community family friends co-workers that
would kind of talk to me along the
journey
our my parents let us live live in their
basement for a little bit her uncle
ended up gifting us a car wow you know
so
and my parents ended up gifting us a car
as well wow
but a really big one especially for
marriages i would say is forgiveness
like because you can
you could use the
the budget as a weapon
if you wanted to
and we do you know anybody that might do
that
i've definitely done it a few times so
yeah
so uh so melissa you had to go uh-uh no
weapon we're working together
um it definitely took a little bit to
actually get on train and stuff but
because i love hobby lobby taser max
target you know there's that
okay so a weapon to control melissa's
spending
okay
all right okay that works too it works
for me i'll go with it hey the good news
is you got on the same page and started
working it together and uh
so what was the
hardest part of this whole process for
y'all
the hardest part of the process i guess
was like the consistent grind but the
the truly hardest was like when i was
out of work so we're
i ended up getting a back injury we're
about almost a year into it and i was
out of work for about eight months whoa
yes uh bad back injury um
my discs were herniated and that some my
mild grades spinal stenosis and that wow
and during that time she kind of really
helped us out with
you know more wedding taking on more
weddings as a photographer than that but
i went through kind of a depression and
that and
ended up
you know adding some more debt
you know through that process and that
and
but god so preserved our lives and you
know
eight months after that we kept kept
going on this whole track and then ended
up two and a half years boom we paid it
all off wow so i wanted to ask you guys
about going into that class financial
peace university i'm just curious
you know it's it's it's like we all
revert to being childlike in our lives
even as adults you know you remember
that first day of kindergarten you know
first day of junior high it's scary
you're walking in i'm curious what was
it like even though it was your church
is that right what was it like to walk
into that class environment this is a
brand new thing uh for you melissa
obviously you're kind of like i don't
know
i'm curious what was the dynamic like as
you went in week in week out
like definitely it was like nervous at
first like i didn't know what to expect
um but definitely i think just like the
workbook and going through that with our
class and like just the slides i just
remember like us having conversations
i think like weekly just talking about
it and like
how it could help our family and all
that stuff so i just it was definitely
mind-boggling definitely took a lot to
take in but it definitely was worth it
what was the part about other people in
the class that maybe brought you into
some comfort level or hey we're not the
only ones talk about that i mean there's
definitely other families in there um
people who like even were childless but
it was just nice seeing other people
that were like us going through the same
things people who had credit cards that
needed
to be done with that and all that stuff
so it was just really nice to know that
we weren't we weren't alone yeah it
makes you feel not so weird that you're
not the only person on the planet that
messed up with exactly
yeah it kind of normalizes that normal's
broke yeah i just don't be normal
anymore yeah yeah well way to go guys it
sounds like you had quite a long journey
there the grind and the the setback and
then coming back after the setback and
well done very well done
very proud of you guys david i want to
ask melissa real quick so wedding
photographer and i'm looking at the two
and a half year timeline here your
wedding's during covet yeah how did you
keep that going
um
kind of stressful but a lot of my
couples i'm very thankful for them they
didn't actually reschedule for the
following year they kept their day
either had a smaller wedding or just
postponed to like another date and i was
available so it was just nice being able
to keep my couples and
yeah it was definitely challenging
especially it's just yeah covered good
for you that's awesome wow very tough
and you brought your daughter with you
what is her name and age her name is
leilani um she is three and a half years
old all right
and this is our why this is why we did
all this just to change that so hi
leilani
girl i love it unicorn squad yeah it's a
good squad to be on i've heard i've
heard i was unaware that it was a squad
i got to do some research dave
you need to catch up on these things
all right way to go guys very proud of
you we got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that's the next chapter in your
story to be baby steps millionaires
you're on your way way to go and a copy
of the total money makeover for you to
give away and get someone else started
on their journey maybe one of those
young couples you're shooting their
wedding you never know you never know
very good stuff all right tyler melissa
and leilani from the cincinnati area
trenton
thousand dollars paid off in two and a
half years making sixty to seventy count
it down let's hear a debt free screen
ready ronnie ready lonnie three two one
words are free
i love it
man that's so fun
it never gets old it never gets old
financial peace university class taught
ramsey plus taught in a in a local
church
somebody jumps in at just the time that
they need it perfect timing and uh and
boom here we set things are going the
way they are supposed to go
very very well done that's a great
testimony too folks if you're
considering going i don't know anybody
there i don't even go to church there
trust me they're going to welcome you
the people that are the coordinators are
some of the finest people i've ever had
the privilege to meet in my life and
then you just heard they're going to be
other people and they have the same
stuff you have there's no shame it's
everywhere just go those people aren't
good with money join a community most
people aren't you he said the communal
party that's right the family helped
them
they were in a group that's a big part
of the process it really is very very
well done you guys proud of you
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
open phones a triple eight eight two
five
five
two two five kansas city's on the line
michael is with us hey michael how are
you
hey dave great to talk to you
sure you too how can we help
i'm calling uh
my mother passed away september of 20.
we are at the end she didn't have a will
we're at the end of the probate
process and we're trying to figure out
what we should do with the house
she owes about 90 thousand dollars
there's some foundation damage i'm not
sure if we sold it as is
it would even be worth
what she owes
my brother uh me and my brother for the
uh
the heirs
um i tried to get him to uh see if he
could get a loan to uh
take over the loan because he wants to
stay there
but he's a convicted felon that's never
really
thought of working other than buying and
selling used cars so he only makes about
twelve thousand dollars a year
how's he gonna pay a thousand dollar a
month payment
well he got uh quite a bit of money from
life insurance and things like that
but if he doesn't work you know that's
gonna run out obviously exactly
so he you know i was like well maybe you
know we can both go in on it but i don't
really want to be involved uh especially
with him
right now um so here's the thing
if the house is worth
90 000 and there's 90 000 odd on it it's
not worth anything to you you could just
let him take it
was um
as the mortgage goes do we need to
you're not on the mortgage are you you
didn't sign the mortgage did you
no here's my mom's mortgage do you have
any idea what kind of mortgage it is
fannie mae fha va
it's a uh just a fha okay then your
brother can take over the payments
without uh having refinanced it
oh we can yeah okay yeah that fha will
not foreclose on an estate
they'll let him just pay the payments as
long as he keeps them current obviously
if he didn't win he quits keeping them
current they'll take the house but yeah
he's been paying the payments since he
passed okay he's living there taking
care of her okay
um i just wanted to have it then
let him just tell him to pay the payment
don't miss a payment though
no well i thought maybe if we put a
little money into it we could probably
sell it for
twice what what she's owed on it and
then make a little money on it
okay that's a different scenario than
what you laid out
you said the house was worth what was
owed on it
yeah if we didn't do any repairs yeah
yeah and how much insurance money did
you and your brother get
uh we ended up getting about 80 000 a
piece
okay and how much in repairs would you
do and then what would the house be
worth if you did those repairs i think
if we put 20 into it we could probably
sell it for 160 to 180
in this market
what do you make a year
i'm like 80
and i'm you know married with kids and
okay
and i got my own mortgage and a second
mortgage to help my kids go to college
but uh
but you got 80 thousand dollars in the
bank
yeah
so do you because here's the thing your
brother would like to stay there if you
guys both put in 10 each
of your insurance money
you know you're going to get that 10
back and another 30 or another 20 or
something right
each right after all the smoke clears
and go through all this trouble and
everything well he would actually get a
little more because he's been paying the
mortgage yeah
okay
um i'm gonna give you some
weird advice
okay
you're signing up for a bunch of hassle
your brother's had a mess of a life and
needs a leg up i'm going to take my 80
000 and let him have the house and walk
away
that's a gift to your brother a little
bit but it's also a gift to yourself
and lack of hassle lack of problems lack
of whatever he was there he took care of
your mom
yes he's paid the payments yes all that
but uh this will give him a good hard
fresh start if he wants to put 20 of his
80 into it and flip it he can make a
little money i don't think he's going to
do that um
and i think you can just walk away from
the hassle and the problems that you're
getting ready to sign up for and do your
do your brother
a favor do something nice for him in the
process i think this is a win-win to
walk away
what do you think right i agree that's a
great idea how much debt do you have
i have uh 20 000 on a second mortgage to
help my kids go to college
yeah so i have a mortgage yeah so i
agree with delta a second bank some of
it for the rest of college that's right
and you got a clean clear life out of
this you guys have gone through the
grieving of losing your mom together um
and i i i want
it to be a clear conversation with him
that i'm giving him a gift that might be
worth as much as twenty thousand bucks
and and that uh that thought process has
come up in our discussions
but uh so i would just really want to
get some advice so i appreciate it yeah
i think this is a good time for
generosity on your part yeah
that's going to benefit everyone it's
just a thought yep i couldn't agree more
dave i think this is a nice move it
takes the kind of takes it off of his
takes it off of his shoulders it's done
i've gifted my brother i've given him an
opportunity and thus doing so i'm not
going to get any more money but i got 80
from mom i'm debt free except the house
it with a stroke of one check uh and
still somebody got some money left
yeah and we're not tied up in some kind
of real estate flip this house crap on
cable tv because you know more about
this than i do but it's never as simple
as well it's just 20. it's just 20 and
then we'll flip it and it's all it
always takes longer and you're trying to
find construction people in a weird
market right now and yeah
i i i just um
you know if there's 150 000 bucks on the
line we might talk about it but there's
not yeah
and when all the smoke clears on this it
might not have been worth the trouble
anyway that kind of thing
so good question
all right daniel's with us in new york
city hi daniel welcome to the ramsey
show
hey guys what's going on
hey how can we help sure
hi okay so my question is my question is
basically and don't get mad at me dave
but
i think i want to lease a car
and i know you're not supposed to lease
a car supposed to buy a used one in cash
but
i think i can afford to lease a car and
i think it's the better move for me
like i'm curious what you have to say on
that
well you kind of know what i'm gonna say
obviously don't you
yeah but maybe um well daniel i think
this is where you lay out your case for
dave you know what he's gonna say so why
do you think it's a better deal than
buying a used car okay good idea
right so why i think is because
i could let's say by uh try to find a
reliable used car for like a 10 or 15
000
but i personally wouldn't feel
comfortable driving that around
in terms of reliability because for work
i'm driving sometimes two hours in the
middle of nowhere
i just don't want to you know risk
anything i want to have
a new car and 10 years from now i don't
want to be driving
a 10 year old car
okay so that's that's why for me
that's why i think and uh i don't have
in your how old
i'm 23. and your house your income is
what
i make uh 120. okay good for you how
many miles you putting on that car
i would probably keep within the ten
thousand miles
a year not if you're driving
a day that's where i had a problem with
your math are you driving four miles an
hour no but it's not it's not every day
i work for myself so i'm more
i'm not working every day
dude you're in prison with those lease
miles but
so wait a minute you can't have it both
ways okay you can't have it i drive two
and a half miles a day i drive two and a
half hours every day so i need a
reliable car but wait a minute no i
don't drive two and a half hours a day i
only drive ten thousand miles a year so
i don't need a reliable car
occasionally i drive two and a half
hours
yeah frequently okay well not frequently
over 10 000 miles
the occasional frequency
it doesn't add up you can't daniel you
can't have it both ways the math doesn't
work in your discussion okay
so here's the thing here's the thing
here's the thing
broke people
drive new cars
there's two people that drive brand new
cars
mega millionaires
and broke people these are the only two
people the vast majority of new cars are
broke people because they go down in
value
like a rock
you're either going to put the miles on
this fleece car you're going to blow the
lease up or you're not going to put the
miles on it and it's going to eat you
alive
you can do what you want to do you call
me there's no possible way i'm going to
tell a 23 year old is smart enough to
make 120 000 to go fleece a stupid car
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit
dot com and register we would love for
you to come to nashville and tell dave
your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality host of the
king coleman show is my co-host today
tomorrow is book launch day for ken his
brand new book from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to
to doing work you love uh is in
bookstores available tomorrow be shipped
tomorrow to those of you that have
pre-purchased it speaking of which if
you pre-order by midnight tonight you
will spend 20 for the book and get a
hundred dollars plus
worth of goodies uh added in included in
the process
and uh man pretty incredible you're
gonna get resume templates guides a
video course the audio book the ebook
all of it included uh all for just
purchasing the 20 book why because
pre-orders matter towards the best
seller list and we bribe you into
pre-ordering
because you're going to get the book
anyway you might as well get all the
goodies so go ahead and order it right
now at ramseysolutions.com while you
have the chance
last day to do that tomorrow is launch
day uh lots of media and stuff happening
this week for you you're gonna be really
busy yeah we're excited we're getting
the word out and uh it's uh it's we
would have never known that the scenario
that we sit in now this great
resignation people considering moving
coming out of the pandemic moving more
than they've ever moved before in their
work because they know that there's more
there they want a bigger paycheck but
they also want to do work that has
more values attached to it so it's very
exciting time to see what's going to
happen as the world shifts certainly the
american workforce is shifting
tremendously and so we're excited about
it going to be talking about it anywhere
we can possibly talk about it yeah so if
you're one of those 55 or so thinking
about changing jobs listen you don't
want to just change jobs
you don't want to go from the frying pan
of the fire
more money and i hate my job in a toxic
environment yeah
you need to be careful what you wish for
right
and so from paycheck to
purpose
making as much or more money than you
make now and get meaning
yeah this is the goal
you don't have to take a 50 pay cut to
be a happy camper yeah matter of fact
that's not going to make you a happy
camper
money doesn't make you happy that's not
the point but the point is you need to
get after this so hey paycheck to
purpose at ramseysolutions.com
get it while you can today with all the
goodies attached daniel's going to start
off this hour in knoxville hi daniel how
are you
hi dave hi ken thanks for taking my call
i'm doing well
great how can we help um so i have a
baby step four question for y'all
um so in order to maintain that 25 ratio
across fund categories in my ira
i feel like i'm only ever thinking money
into the international fund the basis in
that fund is is much higher than the
others and it's growing right so every
time i deposit money it's always into
that international fund because it's
formed not as well as the rest is that
still the correct way to invest or am i
interpreting y'all's advice incorrectly
way to go you're really paying attention
the international category of the four
categories sucks
i mean it's bad
it's ugly
and so you notice that that's a good
thing
and what you're trying to do is
rebalance your portfolio with your
monthly contributions
that's right i would i would not do that
i'm fine if a category's sucking if it
gets a little bit out of balance
because i'm going to end up with less in
a sucky category
okay until it comes roaring back and
then when it comes rolling back i got so
pissed off about this international
category underperforming because i've
given the same information the same and
i personally invest that way my personal
401k is like we're talking about it's 25
into each category period and i have i
don't go back and rebalance some people
go back and rebalance every year or two
and if you want to that's fine it's not
the end of the world but you're not
going to usually see a huge change on
uh your results if you do now what i did
do daniel just as a side note
because you noticed something that a lot
of people haven't really brought up
is that i i considered maybe we need to
change our advice
because that category's so bad maybe we
just need to go third third third and
drop the international because for it's
like a 20-year run of suck i mean it's
it's bad
and so what i did though i went back
with my elp or my smart master pro and i
had him run a whole bunch of scenarios
and i told him what i was thinking about
i said not only am i thinking about
changing mind i'm thinking about
changing because i'm not going to change
mine and not tell y'all
okay i think the market's moved i think
this international category is bad i was
ready to go there and we ran the
scenarios out 14 different ways and they
found all kinds of anomalies and all
kinds of things in the marketplace
because i always look back 30 40 years i
don't look back just three years
or even 15 years right i want to look
back i want to see how this market moves
how it reacts and
they said okay over 40 years here's what
it would look like if you had the
international in your mix at 25 going in
no rebalancing uh back to your original
question and here's what it would look
like if you didn't have the
international
and even though the international sucked
it has offset the other times that the
domestic market is turned down it's shot
up because it runs inverse of the other
markets usually uh enough times that i
actually end up with more money with the
sucky category in there
which is weird
so i left it i left it in my portfolio
and i did not change my recommendations
after running out actual hypotheticals
they're called in that world and running
it out that way but yeah you i would not
recommend to do what you're doing
uh it's not the end of the world if you
do but i think you're working too hard
to get a lame horse to run
and so uh throwing that extra money on
that international so i just put 25 on
everything and if you want to rebalance
or move some around a little bit every
if it gets way out of whack that'd be
fine
but uh i think over a long period of
time the thing will probably pretty
naturally rebalance or get close to it a
long period being 20 30 years not two
years
so that that's the thing i have never
done what you're doing i've always done
25 each period a fourth each i've not
done it not rebalanced with the
contribution rate in order to get it to
catch up um if you do that you're
probably going to be okay but i think
you'll make more money the way i'm
talking about than the way you're doing
it just tonight i think mathematically
that's the way it's going to work if if
when you say to him okay if you do that
it's fine i don't think you're going to
win and you explain why but if someone
was going to do that
what would that allocation look like
instead of 25 well what he's doing is
he's putting
more than 25 into the international
because it's dipping to try to gas try
to catch it try to have it catch up get
the balance to catch up because he's
trying to get his balances to be 25 each
so it just depends on how long you've
been doing it and how far in the hole
that account is i mean you could put 90
percent into the international and for
catch up if you had to you know got it
but i i again i'm not going that route
um
i'm just going to keep plugging along
here here's the interesting thing the
fact that you're looking at this and
you're paying attention you're using
good critical thinking skills and you're
constantly investing and you're
constantly investing and you're
constantly investing that's what we
found in all the data that causes people
to win more than the technicalities the
technicalities
don't end up mattering as much as paying
attention and continuing paying
attention and continuing that's what we
found with all the data on the
millionaires
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
open phones this hour as we talk about
your life and your money this is the
ramsey show ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today aaron is
with us in
charlotte north carolina hi erin welcome
to the ramsay show
hi david ken how are y'all today great
how can we help
yeah so my question is i i
i could apply for a position within my
company that i'm working at now but i'm
not sure if that's the best idea for me
and i'm hoping that y'all could as
unbiased
could help me determine that give you a
little bit of background i've been at
this company for almost five years
and i was promised growth opportunities
whenever i was hired
unfortunately that seemed to be
uh has seemed to be a lie the growth
track that i thought i was on uh doesn't
appear to be
a viable track for a growing so i was
wondering what i can and you might say
about that okay
so in your honest opinion have you been
able to
do everything that you feel like you
could do to be the best that you can be
in the contribution you've made over
that five years and you still feel like
no track for growth no opportunities
have come your way
uh yes and no there's definitely the
potential where i could apply for this
new position and it would be the growth
opportunity that i would want however
i'm being told that uh that the work
that i've been doing over the last
several years do not qualify me for this
position as i was originally led to
believe well
whether you were led to believe that or
not the reality is they're telling you
that the work you're doing now hasn't
qualified you for this other position so
it doesn't seem like that's an absolute
possibility so i think going after
something like that where they've told
you your leadership has told you you're
not qualified it's like me trying to go
outside and dunk a basketball tonight on
a 10-foot rim it's just not going to
happen
and so i it feels like to me we've got
to start
short by the way
and can't jump i've got the double
hurdle there
so i i understand the want to
but the there's the leadership has said
you're not qualified for it and i think
you're setting yourself up for
frustration and disappointment that's
unnecessary when i think it might be
time for you to look elsewhere and i
think really it's about getting clear
aaron let me ask you this okay so if i
understand you right you're
coming in you came into this job and you
were told if you do x y and z
that you'll be able to uh move on to
this type of a position now you've done
x y and z and now they're coming back
and saying that's no not true
what we told you was wrong
uh or what you understood was wrong that
you didn't do x y and z so
uh or even if you do x y and z you're
not qualified is that what you're
telling me
because you've seen the way you the way
you've structured your sentences two
times you've two different times in this
conversation it sounded like you think
you work for liars
well i we i will say i definitely have a
new manager and i think that this new
manager wants me to apply for this new
position however i i feel like i have if
there's no chance of getting it why does
your new manager want you to apply for
it
that's my thing is i don't understand
the thought process behind my managers
and i've tried to get some clarification
and i'm still uncertain uh coworkers are
saying you should just apply just apply
because there's no harm in it and i
understand that but at the same time
it's causing me more frustration and
emotional and mental harm than it is
doing me good trying to fight for
something that i can't get right well
then don't do it and you also have some
concerns so confused i don't know why
you can't get it your manager told you
to apply for it he's not going to tell
you to apply for something you can't get
i honestly i can't tell you why dave
it's been a it's i've been asking for
cross-training opportunities to get a
position like this for
at least three out of the four to five
years that i've been here so why would
your manager tell you to apply for
something that you have zero chance of
getting
that's not logical they haven't told me
specifically to apply for it but i i
just get the sense that they would like
for me too okay but didn't you all so do
you have a sense that they think you're
not qualified do they tell you you're
not qualified
they specifically told there's two
positions available one is a
a lower level position than the actual
position that i'm looking for
and that position both are currently
available one i think she would like for
me to apply for the lower position but
she has told me that i'm not eligible
that i'm not qualified for the higher
position all right but do you even want
the higher position let's just remove
all this for a second all this confusion
back and forth do you even want the
position if you were qualified would you
be jumping for it yeah actually whenever
i begin to apply for the position that i
currently have i originally applied for
that position and they asked for me to
apply that for the position that i
currently have okay so i've been asking
for that position ever since i've been
there oh i get i think there's a pattern
here do you feel that you're qualified
on paper for this role
i think so well no no no i don't want to
think so i mean like do you know if you
look at this position out in the
marketplace like if you went somewhere
else you could make a case
when you're being interviewed that you
should be able to get this job done
so you feel you're qualified i believe
so okay i think it's time to start
looking
today
let's start looking let's test the
market
let's find out there's a there's a gap
here between you feel like well dave's
right i feel like you feel like they're
dishonest we're not we're not saying
you're wrong we're just saying it's all
over you you feel like they've been
dishonest with you they're not giving
you an opportunity we've got previous
management saying you're not qualified
new person comes in i think she
there's too much this stuff going on
getting your extreme job with dishonest
people is not your dream job yeah
that's my thought process as well dude
yeah so you move on yeah if that's if
that's that's why i was asking where
your head was on that issue because you
know if you feel like that because
they're going to cut your knees out from
under you if they're going to catch you
right if that's who they are uh if
that's if that's the real conclusion
that you've come to now you beat around
the bush in this conversation
you've not been clear with us we've had
to pull this out of you so keep in mind
i mean i don't know whether you're
trying to be nice or what you're trying
to do but you know bottom line is the
issue here is you don't trust your
leadership and that means it's time to
move yeah listen folks when you feel
there's a lid on you whether you know
all the reasons or not start looking
elsewhere because it's only a matter of
time before you become bitter and then
this thing can turn toxic on your end
and you end up burning a bridge and
hurting your future because you're just
sitting around kind of e-warring you
know you got to move on and i think i'd
start looking today again this is such a
great time to look and this is where we
find out by the way
if if we are qualified yeah if you go
out there and can't get the job then
maybe they were right that's right they
weren't dishonest they were just being
honest they were telling you the truth
you're not qualified we've got to find
the common denominator in this situation
yeah
is it him that'll do it or is it
leadership go do some interviews if you
don't get the job then you'll know
that's what's going on so at least
hypothetically you'll know yeah so um
yeah the other thing you can do is have
some very clear
precise language not like you used with
us
uh discussions with some leaders
in the organization and go listen i
really feel like this is what i was
promised i feel like i've lived up to it
so i'm really struggling with why i
shouldn't get this position can you show
me what i need to do to be able to
follow through on what i thought we were
doing
and that's a very clear concise
set of words yeah and you don't have to
accuse somebody of lying with to do that
you can just challenge out the situation
say i need to know
why it is that after five years and
having done these things that that i'm
not able to do the thing that i thought
that i signed up for
to get to see this is very important
folks make sure you hear what dave said
most weak leaders they're just weak i
mean doesn't mean they're bad people but
weak leaders
don't communicate clearly they're afraid
of confrontation so by being honest like
dave just described that kind of very
clear very clear put the ball in their
court and if you give them a clear
question and they don't give you clear
back there's your answer this is weak
leadership they're never going to tell
me what i need to hear because we need
to hear it but it takes us being honest
what kind of value do i need to add to
be qualified yes and when i do that then
what you're saying is then i get the
role right and if if they look at you
and go one of the things you have to
learn is clear communication
it might be it could be that could be
the comeback you know yeah so um
it's a possibility
so that's the kind of stuff but there's
nothing wrong with testing the waters
and going and interviewing
especially if you've lost faith in the
integrity of the organization that's
really when it's time to move on
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com slash ken sign up today
absolutely free and let zip recruiter
work for you
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
mike and christy are with us hey guys
how are you great dave how about you
good to have you where do you guys live
matt menville tennessee oh just over the
hill just over the hill well thanks for
joining us here guys great and how much
debt have you all paid off fifty six
thousand nine hundred and eighty four
dollars in the past 18 months wow that
was quick and your range of income
during that time a hundred thousand
between the two cool what do you all do
for a living i'm a tool maker in a
plastic injection company she's a
kindergarten kindergarten teacher at
eastside elementary all right fun
very fun so what kind of debt was your
57 000 oh a lot of fun
credit cards truck
jeep
house
kind of normal that's normal oh you paid
off your house yeah in the 57 000.
wow
wow okay very cool looking at weird
people yeah
okay so you had normal debt yes and and
have been going along how long y'all
been married 24 years okay and you look
up 18 months ago and decided to do this
crazy ramsay stuff what happened um well
actually my mother had given me a book
in 92 when i got my first home and uh
she's always preached to me about
saving and working and not being in debt
and paying for cash for things and of
course i ignored all of it and had a lot
of fun and running up credit card bills
about about 10 000 in that and um
you felt like you didn't have i didn't
have a way out
um you feel trapped you smell you feel
smothered
um but then it uh you started seeing
progress you know and then 18 months ago
you know we
we decided that you know i'm tired of
this and let's let's get out of it we
started following your baby steps and i
was marking off each day we started with
the lowest and kept marking them off and
just visually seeing that
just made a difference for us and then
we printed off your little bricks on the
house where you mark off the bricks
and course that helped us keep going and
and we have two children in college too
so we did all of this while we're paying
for college too
and two others over here wow where are
they in college um one is at utc and one
is at tennessee tech and thankfully they
did the community college thing for two
years
in both affordable schools that they're
in for your school yeah so you're not
yes you can go crazy on that yeah so
that's good the scholarships so in 1992
your mother gave you one of my books
the little blue one yeah it has to be
because that's the first first year
i said that's the one i won't sign i
want one mom that's that's the uh that
thing's a classic i mean
92 is the first year that it came out i
saw those out of the trunk of my car
just like that car over there oh
see that's vintage
vintage i like that i'm slow reader
yeah that was slow on the uptick but
yeah
just took 30 years to get around to it
that's awesome but then okay so what
happened 18 months ago that was the wake
up call that made you get so intense
well
i i was really pushing it i'll be honest
and i just
wanted him to get on board with me and
uh i would we would just be very
intentional about our spending and i
kind of started doing the minimalist
thing where less is more and
that helped out a whole lot and
it wasn't easy because i had a
bump in the road i had a stage one
breast cancer diagnosis last year in
august
so that kind of set us back a little bit
but i went through the radiation
treatments and we just kept persevering
and
we're here now and your cancer free now
cancer-free now it's been a year
that free cancer free what a year
it was like for us the budget
working on the budget that was probably
the hardest part for me because when you
put it on paper and
you see i mean there was actually a few
years back when the kids were just born
not just the twins but nolan and katie
i was working she was at home with the
kids and it's a lot of stress and you're
asking for overtime and you're just
trying to break even because at 40 hours
there was a time that
you know 94 a week i was in the hole
at 40 hours a week
and that's a lot of stress on my dad and
a marriage in the home and and it just
builds on you and and
as we the past 18 months you see that
light at the end of that tunnel when one
gets paid off you get the credit card
paid off you get the trip to paid off
you get the truck paid off you get and
it just starts snowballing just like you
know it's like you teach you know you
see that hope and uh it's i didn't know
how much stress i really had
because it'd been there for so long yeah
and once you start getting to the end of
it it's like man what can i do i mean
it's like i look at everything totally
different now it's
um
what what can i do you know instead of
what i can i can't do it's like i told
my wife instead of buying on time i want
to live on my time now i don't i don't
want i don't want to
just struggle and i like it and we want
to give god all the glory because and
this none of this would be possible
without him
we definitely put him first in our lives
and
we're here now because of him
yeah we i mean we've been blessed with
with with health and things that bumps
comes along but it's still was still
worked out and uh
again getting to work through a pandemic
nothing you know i didn't have to worry
about any of that it could still work
and still go and still do and
it's just been a blessing i mean it's
pretty cool yeah so christy i gotta go
back in the story because i think i'm
missing something here and i want to
make sure i'm catching on what's
happening okay so we go along and about
18 months ago
you somehow connected to us fresh
um i had been listening to you oh you
had been listening for a while
several years you just kind of turned up
the old heat a little bit in your sweet
little way yes and i was listening to
your daughter too and um okay and you
know okay so you just kept turning it up
a little bit turning it up because we
did try this
several years back yes and um it just i
gave up yeah we weren't on board and we
weren't intentional with it so we just
became intentional and
this
paid off
look at mike he's he's going through
active recovery right there
yeah it's the truth that is the truth
yeah i could see it hey mike i do want
to ask you because you shared some
really gut-wrenching stuff there and i
think a lot of people feel very all
right what's it like on the other side
and i mean i want you to now drive now
that you're free i want you to describe
because you said you didn't know what it
felt like because you'd had it so long
so now on the other side what is the
positive emotional and physical peace
that you have
you're not trapped i mean and what i
mean by that is i mean i love my job i
mean i've been a tool maker all my life
in my working life
and you know i've been there since 92
you know for coming up on 30 years
but you feel
um
i don't i don't owe anybody anything you
know i can give
we have some very dear friends you know
lost a daughter to cancer during all
this you know almost well not a year ago
but
i want to help and i want to help i want
you know if it's just giving something
to saint jude or if it's just doing i
just want to help yeah and and those
opportunities you can you you see
you you see somebody that's alone and
eating
at a restaurant i i i
i'm not a secret's out i guess now but i
try to i want to buy their lunch and
just let them not know and just go just
the little things you know nothing big
but just
you can just do those things and not
worry you can be a little you're a
little kinder you're a little nicer it's
a little sweeter at home i mean because
i mean the family's growing and and
we're just kind of off and running and
you wanna you can step and watch and you
know i i had uh uh covered in in august
and i missed the month of work but guess
what there was a savings and i didn't
have to worry about it you know and it's
just those types of things that you see
it working
and it's great and it's
yeah and you brought two of your
daughters with you what are their names
christian and kerrigan okay and they're
they're the twins they're twins okay how
old are they 15. all right
so here comes some more college yeah i
like it but now we're ready we're ready
game off we're ready i'm so proud of
y'all congratulations thank you very
well done what's this house worth you
paid off um probably about 350. yeah
awesome
on our way to being baby steps
millionaires then that's welding nice
well you're right there you're going to
be there for you know it well done you
guys we got a copy of the legacy journey
for you copy a total money makeover
maybe you can give it away to somebody
and they'll read it before 1992. yes we
hope to help others definitely i love it
all right count it down gang 57 000 paid
off in 18 months making 100 a year count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're dead
that's gold right there man yeah that is
cool there's so much in that
so much going on that's fun mike might
get in trouble for getting ahead of the
count there he might he might you never
know this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day philippians 3
13 and 14 one thing i do forgetting what
is behind and straining toward what is
ahead i press on toward the goal to win
the prize for which god has called me
heavenward
in christ jesus
serena williams said don't let anyone
work harder than you do
that's important right there guys it's
almost time for christmas it's going to
sneak up on you but for some of you what
should be a time of joy tradition
togetherness
is stress
you're stressing over how you're going
to pay for presents
the big grocery bills
the stuff
doesn't have to be that way
when you have a plan
you have confidence instead of stress
and when everything else seems out of
control financial peace university will
show you how to put that plan in place
you're going to learn step by step how
to get out of debt
save money build wealth be outrageously
generous you put the plan into practice
by budgeting with every dollar it syncs
up easily with your bank you can track
your spending you can finally see where
your money goes you get all of this with
a ramsey plus membership and that's the
only way to get it
you don't have to live through a
stressed out christmas
make 2022
the year you start winning because right
now you start a free trial of ramsey
plus plus by texting trial 233
789 a free trial by texting trial two
three three
seven
eight
nine kevin is in orlando hi kevin
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so um my wife and i um we have a baby on
the way we just purchased a house
together
i'm trying to decide whether my previous
house which i had paid off whether i
should throw all that at my mortgage or
invest that you know in the market in
some kind of safe conservative mutual
funds
well uh you're debt-free other than the
homes
uh we have a car payment but just going
gonna pay that off uh once we get the
new money from the house
okay so the the the original house
you're talking about is sold or is going
to be sold
and how much are you going how much are
you going to receive from it
um about 550.
550 000 clear
yes sir
okay and how much do you owe in your car
um
just under 60 000. and what do you owe
on your home
uh 800 000. and what's your household
income
uh just about 400 000 a year wow way to
go dude what do you guys do for a living
thank you
um we're both in healthcare okay
congratulations very well done great
careers okay
um well what we have found
is that the first one to five million
dollars of net worth that people get is
typically from a paid for house
and their retirement accounts in 401ks
403 b's iras
our baby step number
one is save a thousand dollars you've
obviously done that two is to be
debt-free everything with the house we
got a plan to pay off the sixty thousand
dollar car which is going to leave us
490 000 with an 800 000 mortgage baby
step three is saving three to six months
of expenses how much
non-retirement saving and investing do
you currently have
uh
just under nine hundred thousand
non-retirement yes
mutual sorry um money market account and
uh savings okay
uh what i would do if i woke up in your
shoes is i would pay off my house
100 okay
now you're sitting there with a paid for
house a four hundred thousand dollar
income you have an emergency fund set
aside of three to six months of expenses
and now there's nothing left to do but
build wealth
and be outrageously generous but no
house payment is going to get you there
and here's what you're going to find
okay you're in a high stress environment
that is emotionally and intellectually
fatiguing agreed
correct
you're going to feel something that you
don't anticipate that your intellect
doesn't tell you you're gonna feel when
you pay off this house you're gonna feel
a release
a sense of peace
because it's like having a backache and
you've had it so long you don't even
realize it's there and you don't think
about it but when it's gone you're like
wow
i just got set free
that's pretty incredible so
um that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
pay off that house that's the way i have
lived personally and once i got there it
was fairly easy to become very very
wealthy with that kind of income and not
a payment in the world plus you don't
have a care in the world
in the middle of weirdness and dude
you've experienced some weirdness in
healthcare in the last 24 months agreed
yes sir
yeah and and so one less thing you know
i have two i've had all kinds of stress
around the business and trying to keep
this thousand people employed and
revenues going up revenues going down
entire areas of revenue disappearing and
trying to run this thing but i never had
the stress of worrying about a
foreclosure i never had the stress of
worrying about if i personally was going
to be left out in the cold because it
was all paid for there's a release there
the borrower's slave to the lender and
when you're 100 debt free there's a
freedom that's going to cause you to
prosper yet even more changes your
decision making paradigm it really does
and and you're right this at this stage
where they are at this is the right move
it sets them up for their future serious
serious good position you've gotten
yourself into well done
catherine's in london hi catherine
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi ken thank you very much for
taking my call and this is my first time
calling in so i'm thrilled to have got
through well we're honored to have you
how can we help
um okay so my question um
so essentially i'm in a job that i don't
love um
but i have the equivalent of about 25 27
000 worth of debt
that i need to pay off my job is well
paid
and i make about
98 000
equivalent um
before tax um then i
i i want out and but then i i've got
this debt that i need to pay i have an
eight-year-old son
he's in private school um that i'm
paying for um
and
my question essentially is
how do i plan
an exit from a job that i don't love
yeah well do you like it
okay well a couple things don't walk
into this with the assumption that if
you change jobs that you have to take a
big pay cut and we're not going to jump
off of a cliff here we don't want to see
any interruption in income so catherine
if there's no interruption in income and
you can step into something else that is
much more enjoyable
that doesn't have all the factors at
play that's going on with what's going
on now you wouldn't even be calling us
you'd be like okay and so let's let's
start with the assumption that we're not
going to have an interruption in income
okay that's first but the question is do
you know what you would love to do or is
there a job that you are very intrigued
by a career path that you've always
wanted to
pursue um
to be honest i'm not sure i'm i'm 45 um
and i kind of feel like that's so i work
in healthcare and i've worked in
healthcare for 25 years okay um
and i have been looking at other roles
that are within my field but i quite and
you know
it's um
it's quite a thriving industry at the
moment but every role that i come across
i just i don't even bother to read the
whole
job specs but i'm just not interested
and i just i don't know if it's because
you know if it's a combination of
um
part of the reason why i don't love my
job okay all right so let me know
or the pandemic i kind of feel like i
don't want to do this anymore yeah well
you have to listen to that but here's
what i want you to do
you've got some debt you make really
good money and you've got some debt that
you can pay off
pretty quickly if you stay focused so
for right now catherine i want you to
stay in this job i know you don't love
it i know you want out but let's change
our attitude the attitude is hey i'm
grateful for this job because it's
taking care of me my eight-year-old son
and it's allowing me to pay off debt and
i'm going to stay put until i've got
something to step into
so that's our focus so here's what i
want to do kelly let's give kathryn
a link to the get clear career
assessment that we sell here ramsey
solutions kencoleman.com would you take
the assessment it's going to point out a
whole lot to you that you've never seen
before and then let's come up with a
clear path hang on we're going to give
you the brand new from paycheck to
purpose because it's the field guide to
the mountain that the assessment will
point out both of these tools catherine
will show you the direction that you
need to go walk through it stage by
stage don't interrupt your income and
you're going to be fine
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts